it looks like we have time for one more  stain removal question  someone named sheila take a look hi drew  sheila from santa clarita first time  color long time fan  i have a same dilemma don't you hate it  when people talk over you  i do this guy used to have that problem  used to doesn't anymore any tips on how  to get blood out of  clothes walls hair carpet  silverware you know what let's start  with this sweatshirt  sheila interesting we are unfortunately  out of time  darn it but i'm also pretty sure you  should be calling the feds as we speak  that said all the things that you listed  in your passion for stain removal  you seem like my kind of girl best of  luck to you  [Music]